i just want to start i guess by asking
how you feel
about what's going on in this country i
keep telling our people in pakistan that
this would not even have made news here
you know the in in time of covered 19
uh prime minister having a drinks
get together after work would not even
have made news here because we also
unlike the rest of the world we also had
to cope with government 19 and all the
restrictions
so
you know
here people can't understand what's
going on but i understand and i in one
way
this is one thing which i
feel that the reason why british
parliamentary system works
whereas
apart from
non
anglo-saxon countries it doesn't work
because of the very high
level of moral standards you expect from
your leadership
so
unfortunately it doesn't work in other
countries where they do not have the
level of moral standards that you you
expect from your parliamentarians right
i mean i think that the issue here
really is not about partying it's about
the hypocrisy and double standard of a
prime minister who himself was fined by
the police for breaking his own lockdown
rules and over 80 of his own downing
street staff were also fined by the
police and it's the brazen double
standard of a group of people that were
ordering the british public
not to go even go and see dying
relatives dying from covert in hospital
they couldn't do that and at the same
time the people making those very
draconian rules
were brazenly breaking them themselves i
think that's the issue
what stood out in britain was that high
level i repeat of
moral standards you expect from your
leadership
in pakistan you know the vote of no
confidence against me which took place
the whole country knew that the going
rate to buy my parliamentarians was a
million dollars
so i mean if you compare the two
uh that's why you know in my opinion and
i keep telling them of my experience in
british
of parliament that unless we raise our
level of morality to what you have in
britain
parliamentary democracy will not work if
you if all it takes is to buy 20 of your
members of parliament to switch sides
and a government falls
it it it
in fact it's the whole concept of
democracy or parliamentary democracy
then gets challenged so you know from br
from your point of view in britain of
what i know
i understand that you expect from your
leadership the standards you expect them
to delete by example
it's been very volatile since you were
deposed
uh you vowed to come back and fight
again you think you're going to win with
a bigger majority i believe
but one issue that's come up in the last
few days there appears to be a serious
threat of assassination against you and
i have to say the last leader of
pakistan i spoke to was benazir bhutto
and it wasn't long after i met her that
she was indeed assassinated so this is a
very serious
risk that you all face i think when you
lead a country like pakistan
what do you know about these threats how
seriously are you taking them
well
because what happened was that this was
clearly a conspiracy and
you know i've spoken about the
conspiracy because you know i came to
know about it about six months before i
actually
uh before this vote of no confidence
took place
and uh
you know all the time i thought it
wouldn't succeed you know for some
reason i thought that
it's not possible that you know the
conspiracy was to replace me
by the guys who for 30 years had been in
power the two
families
and they were massive corruption cases
against them
60 of the cabinet that has replaced me
is on bail
or billions of rupees of corruption
cases so my mind just wouldn't accept
that
would it be possible to replace our
government which was which had finally
recovered from all the two years of
crises and was on the way up
i just didn't think it would be replaced
by these criminals
so
those who sort of planned this whole
thing
uh a bit worried now because they don't
want me back they didn't
take me out to get me back in again
so that's when i got
i found out that they had uh planned
this final solution but you were known
imran as on the cricket field you were
known as completely fearless no opponent
ever
put fear into you but when you're a
political leader and you're in the
situation that you're in now
where there's a genuine threat against
you of assassination do you feel fear
no you know beers i at his well when i
entered politics i actually had
conquered my fear of dying otherwise i
would not have entered politics because
i came in to stand up against the entire
status quo i came
came to fight corruption
today the entire political
spectrum
16 parties on one side and i'm on the
other side
and because this was the status quo
which has
60 years of our last 62 years half has
been ruled by military and half by these
two families so i came to fight these
two families and this is really what i
i've done and they
have made so much money out of this that
they obviously
clearly someone like me is a threat and
and that's why this uh
foreign-backed conspiracy involving
local players took place now i know that
they would try to my life has had
various threats over a period of time
but this time
i found out about this conspiracy so i
went public the reason i have no fear of
dying but it is it was important to let
those guys were planning to let them
know that i know right it was actually
in a way a form of protection you went
to moscow
as it turned out on the very day that
vladimir putin the russian leader
invaded ukraine and you know how
controversial the images of you and
putin then immediately became because it
looked like you were almost endorsing
what he was doing because you stayed in
moscow and completed your trip
do you regret
now not just leaving immediately you
heard that he'd invaded ukraine
i promise you i had no idea i arrived
the night before i was only there for
one night next morning when i wake up i
discovered that this uh
uh
ukraine adventure had started
now it was uh we discussed amongst
ourselves
we realized that it was very poor timing
but at the same time we realized that we
really it was extremely important for
the 220 million people of pakistan that
we actually uh get these i mean i
understand that i understand basically i
completely understand that you didn't
know before you made the trip i guess
the criticism which may be legitimate is
that once you knew what he'd done
to then stay
there
and still go through with the meetings
that you had planned
sent the world a message that you
were not that upset by what he was doing
in ukraine countries like us
you know who have huge populations and
we have 100 million people who are
vulnerable right now so we should
actually
make policies have be have relationship
with everyone but make policies that
benefit our people i understand that
india is doing i understand what i would
say back to that is we talked earlier
about the higher morality standards in
the uk when it comes to holding leaders
to account
i simply would say i don't criticize you
for having planned a trip to moscow but
i think there is legitimate criticism
that once you knew what he had done it
illegally invaded a sovereign democratic
country did your moral instinct not tell
you
that it would be wrong to stay there
that you should have just got straight
out of there
yes i am against all military operations
i am i i marched with the with those two
million people in in london against iraq
war i constantly was against the
afghanistan war that there was no
military solution i do not believe what
putin has done of trying to find a
military solution in ukraine i always
believe these are miscalculations they
cause a lot of hardship and i did give a
statement in when i was in moscow that
military is not the military actions are
not a solution unfortunately we were
left at it at the the time was
either we then
and by the way the meeting was
more or less an r uh before
when we discovered that the the
they had invaded ukraine it was a
question a one hour in between to decide
whether we abandoned the trip or
or or or have the meeting with putin and
so eventually we decided that look at
this stage we will fall between two
stools
with russia we will break all
relationship leaving at this juncture
and at the at the same time you know is
it going to make any difference if we if
pakistan decides to sort of uh show uh
condem russian invasion by leaving there
are you in a position now to see what
putin has done in ukraine
and emphatically publicly denounce it
any conflict and especially which where
you go and
any conflict creates bloodshed but
you know just like uh
in iraq in afghanistan god knows how
many people died there and similarly in
ukraine
going into uh ukraine the sort of
what we are saying right now
i am i'm sure that uh if president putin
realized what was happening right now he
wouldn't have uh uh started this but do
you personally condemn
the war in ukraine now knowing what
you've seen in the last three months
piers
let me just say one thing i
you know i am basically anti against all
uh operations
so if you if you want to uh ask me a
question
uh do i condemn what is happening in
what happened in iraq i thought it was
wrong and i would condemn that i have
afghanistan u.s going in and then
staying okay once they
once they got decimated al-qaeda in the
first year what was the purpose of
staying there for the next 19 years so
it was a useless war and yes if you know
if i would advising president putin i
would not have gone there and yes a war
that creates bloodshed
and which is which it is and collateral
damage and civilians
yes let me ask you about afghanistan
because from the moment the americans
led the rather dramatic and chaotic and
many think disastrous
overnight pull out from afghanistan of
its forces
it seems the taliban have basically
wrestled back control of the country at
record speed and are now going back to
running the country how the taliban did
before notably with severe oppression of
women in afghanistan what is your view
of that because you've been broadly
supportive i think of the taliban being
able to run the country again but are
you supportive of the way they treat
women there
let the people of afghanistan decide
which way they will go they're strong
people i found women are strong in my
opinion given a chance you will see them
asserting their rights but the last
thing we should do is
try to interfere in people of uh the
with the afghan government they're very
proud people i know from experience that
at any hint of outside interference in
their uh
any country interfering in their way of
life they will
they're very uh
defensive about it i want to take you
back to the
late 70s the early 80s to
the genteel world of cricket uh where
you were a champion cricketer you were a
handsome playboy on the british social
scene
with a number of girlfriends to make all
of us jealous
life was a lot easier for you then a lot
more fun a lot more carefree
you've become a very
powerful
very
divisive in some ways political figure
now in pakistan do you ever have any
regrets do you ever wish you hadn't gone
down the political path for me you know
life is not about
i feel that
you know people who find the easy way of
life
easy way of life for me a purposeless
existence means nothing to me i have you
know i have everything i've ever wanted
in life so for me the challenge is
to actually go back make pakistan a
welfare state and
rule of law critical thing is
what you're seeing in britain is
basically rule of law which is one thing
i learned most of all when i went to
england as an 18 year old imran khan
it's great to talk to you again it's
been
well nearly 50 years since i last talked
to you
uh last time i was steaming at you in
the net hove county cricket ground so
it's it's great to catch up with you
again and i wish you all the very best
thank you very much my pleasure
you